what's happening you bad [__]
it's wednesday
july the 21st the joint is brought to
you and i want to welcome
to the podcast freeze pipe listen
remember for years i've been telling you
[__]
that when i lived in colorado i used to
wake up in the morning and scoop
[__] snow and put it in my bung and
it was tremendous
and then in l.a we were putting ice
cubes in our [__] bongs
and people like what the [__] is that
i've never seen that come on guys
you know uncle joey's a [__]
professional smoking weed doesn't have
to hurt your lungs
with freeze pipe you can get an icy cold
hit
every time it comes with a detachable
chamber
you freeze beforehand that's how it
works
the smoke passage to the frozen part and
cools down the smoke
as you inhale like a doctor it's just
like putting the ice cubes in a bong
but better it's non-toxic it freezes
faster than water and it stays frozen
longer whether you hit it with a pipe a
bubbler a bong or a dab
they got it all what you're looking at
is the pipe and the bubbler i got the
bong
for myself you know what i'm saying they
got it all but i gotta at least have one
of them
so if you can smoke from it freeze pipe
[__] makes it so do me a favor
go to freezepipe.com and pressing code
joey
to save 10 off your first [__] order
let me tell you something these bongs
are [__] tremendous
get your bong your pipe or your bubbler
today
i have not tried the bubbler or the pipe
i've tried the [__] bong
with the frozen and i gotta tell you
it's [__] tremendous
so do me a favor go to freezepipe.com
right now
press and code joey and i'm going to
save you 10 off
your first order that's freezepipe.com
pressing code joey to save 10
of your order if you're gonna go deep
you might as well go deep
with the freeze pipe whether it's a bong
pipe or bubbler
you're gonna [__] see the devil
that's gonna be the [__] result
and it's perfect because you could put
laughing gas in the [__] pipe
and really get the [__] party started
so go
to freezepipe.com right now today
pressing code joey
and save 10 off your first order you
might as well do something with that
[__] government money [__] get
a bong
so you remember we can call it biden for
all i give a [__]
freezepipe.com press and code joey
the joint is also brought to you by
upstart
are you afraid to look at your credit
card statement every month
when you're in debt it can feel like a
never-ending [__] cycle trust me
i was there for [__] 30 years upstart
can help
upstart is the fastest and easiest way
to get a personal loan to pay off your
debt
listen it sucks to be in debt i was in
debt until [__] 2009 until i got
[__] married
and it [__] sucked and i've been in
debt all my [__] life
whether it's paying off credit cards or
consolidating
your debt over half a million people
have used up start
to get a simple fixed monthly payment
it's just five minute online rate check
this means they can offer a smarter rate
to you with trusted partners
you can get approved the same day and
you can receive funds
as fast as one business day is
if that is taking over your life it's
time to get a fresh start
with upstart find out how upstart can
lower your monthly payments
today when you go to upstart.com
joey i know you're in debt at least give
it a [__] look
that's upstart.com joey don't forget to
use
the url to let them know i sent you got
to throw in this in the disclaimer loan
amounts will be determined based on your
credit income and certain
other information provided in your loan
application
and now go to upstart.com
joey and get out of debt today uncle
joey's helping you
get out of [__] debt so do me a favor
go to upstart.com
joey let's get this [__] [__]
started
on a beautiful wednesday morning it's
not beautiful
it's kind of raining now there you go
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
it's wednesday the 21st
of [__] july it's been a beautiful
day so far i had to give some [__]
blood this morning
you know how that goes [__] no drama
i gotta be honest with you guys no
[__] drama at all there was no
fainting i didn't even feel the needle
i always laugh because thank god my wife
goes
thank god my [__] wife goes i'm
sitting there the lady was from another
country who knows what country she was
from
she was very sweet and i told her when i
go in she goes you're gonna sit down i
go
i'm not sitting in that little [__]
communist chair you know they have those
little chairs like
that you put your it looks like a school
kid chair
you know give it a [__] arm i i'm not
[__] sitting on there you know
cuz i'll [__] pass out she goes
really i go yeah so i tell everybody
that right off the bat
i go use the kid needle now i'm fine i
got my earphones on i'm listening to
[__] def leopard high and dry i'm in
[__] heaven i'm thinking about 1982
and
getting my dick sucked and you know
you're trying to think about great
thoughts you know and
i give her the arm and all of a sudden i
can't hear her
you know she's talking to me but i can't
really [__] hear her
and i don't give a [__] and all sudden i
feel my wife closing my hand
but before she closes it she makes like
a noise and next thing you know she puts
a bunch of tissues in my hand
and a bunch of tissues in this hand
because i was sweating [__] profusely
in fact i had my hand on my chest and
when i took it off there was an imprint
of my [__] hand
from how much i was [__] sweating so
i love all that [__]
i didn't even feel the need to go in i
could lie to you and tell you i didn't
feel it
all of a sudden i just felt to put my
arm back and i'm like
thank god i'm gone i was pissed because
i didn't drink enough water because they
usually make you piss in the cup
i get flashbacks of the halfway house
you know i gotta go and then hide i'm
like what am i hiding from nobody's
watching me
so i [__] you know i didn't ask me to
[__] um pee in a cup which was good
because i didn't have enough [__]
fluid in me
you got to go to those blood tests with
nothing in your stomach and i take it
it's a nightmare not to wake up and eat
it's a [__] nightmare for a guy like
me
and to put a needle in your arm with
nothing in your stomach it even makes it
worse
but i [__] make it through i don't
know how the [__] i do it so
thank god that's over i am actually
feeling
a lot [__] better you know than what
i was so
that's [__] great i took a tremendous
[__] this morning and it wasn't like a
little
i've been taking these little submarine
shits for the last three weeks
i'm like that's not my [__] that's
somebody else's [__] i don't take
these little
they look like you yodels you know you
ever seen a yodel like the little
chocolate things
not this morning jack everything came
out you know i'm saying my stomach was
giving me a hard time for a few days
i slowed up on the nicotine gum i
started drinking a little ko pectate
and boom i'm [__] like a [__]
animal again you understand me put them
on the [__] stall
but i'm a little pissed off because i
found out the other day they're not
gonna be making oreos in new jersey no
more
they're gonna [__] outsource oreos
from mexico what the [__] is going on
is biden [__] up this much that even
they took oreos from [__] the united
states
and they're gonna make them in mexico
now i mean i got nothing against the
mexicans i love the [__] mexicans
but this is [__] oreo is an american
[__] tradition
how the [__] are you gonna outsource
oreos to mexicans
this is not good guys this is what i'm
talking about this is what i'm [__]
talking about
listen i don't get pissed about [__]
children at the border i don't know
but taking oreos from the [__]
country jesus christ
how un-american is that first it was
chevrolet
then it was this now it's [__] oreos
those oreos are gonna be [__]
cocained out too
those narcos are going to trick us and
[__] they're going to sprinkle coke in
them
they're going to have a different flavor
to them i'm i'm not happy about this
[__]
i'm not happy about oreos being made out
of mexico
right away you people going are you you
[__] racist i'm not [__] i love
[__] mexican people
as a matter of fact the podcast i'm
doing today is
i miss la i do miss la i miss
different things about l.a when i did
the podcast with lee a couple weeks ago
we talked about the hellish side of la
and i didn't exaggerate you know but
there was some good in l.a and i forgot
to mention that
you know i miss a lot of people and it's
not the people that you think i miss
you know you people think i miss like
the stars i don't miss those
[__] at all
i miss the little guys i miss eric rocha
my [__] gay buddy i haven't made
friends with a gay guy here
i don't hear no more [__] in the ass
stories i had a [__] guy with a
hemorrhoid stories i don't hear none of
that [__] no more
my life is boring now i need another gay
guy in my life you know what i'm saying
he's raping guys he's [__] making him
eat hot dogs to prep him to suck dick
you know
i loved all those stories [__]
tremendous eric roach i miss him
it was lee's birthday yesterday i missed
that little [__] you know
uh i miss steve simone i miss eric rocha
who's having surgery today wednesday the
21st my heart goes out to him
please stop by eric roach's page and
give him some love i mean he's one of my
best
[__] buddies of all time i miss a lot
of guys rodrigo
but the guy i'm gonna have on the
podcast today is a special [__] cat
uh we've been friends since
i met him when they sent me to l.a
to do the tryouts for latino laugh
festival
him and marilyn martinez were my first
buddies in [__] la
and he was
always great to me from day one he would
yell out from the back of the room what
jokes for me to say he wanted to hear
the dirtiest [__] jokes
he took me to all the mexican rooms in
south la he introduced me to all the
mexicans as his brother
i mean you know when i cracked the oreo
cookie it was just a [__] joke you
know
no it's not i'm pissed off that mexico's
got it but
let's not even [__] discuss that
right now i'm not pissed at mexico
they're just trying to make a decent
buck you know uh
he introduced me to all the mexican
[__] dudes he showed me all the great
taco places where
you know me and this cat must have done
[__]
a thousand shows together like that's
you know he had a room on tuesdays and
thursdays on tuesdays and wednesdays
that they gave me an open invite to
like it was guaranteed forty dollars and
a burrito
forty dollars and a burrito back then
meant more to me
than anything in the world you ask any
artist
when he's [__] starving what would
you rather have cash
or quick meal and a [__] taco to go
or something and they'll tell you
the food i mean the experiences i had
with this guy were tremendous
uh if i look at my 30 years of comedy
he was in those 15 of those [__]
years you know the guys that were
the best to me i think in comedy were
mexicans
i had jimmy abate in denver that guy got
me started
that guy got me on the hbo tour that guy
[__] gave me two gigs a week he
[__] paid my rent jimmy a beta i
i will forever be grateful for him
but felipe esparza was my [__] uh
original og i mean i had him and george
perez and rudy moreno and gilbert
esquivel
you know gilbert used to book at the
laugh factories on monday night latino
night
and even though the owner of the laugh
factory was like you're not ever
performing in here today
uh anymore when i first got there he
wasn't out there on monday nights at the
laugh factory
so gilbert would put me up on the
sweetest [__] spot
half the movies i got and have the tv
shows i got
were from the [__] laugh factory
latino nights on monday night
and it would be me pablo
felipe willie barcena edwin san juan the
lineups jeff garcia
george perez the lineups were [__]
deadly
latino night on laugh factory but
even when i did my documentary
if you look at the documentary it's
executive produced
by this guy you're about to see today
he's one of my tightest friends in
comedy
i miss him with all my heart and i'm
happy he came on the joint
we talked it's a very if you're looking
for [__] huge laughs you're not gonna
get him it's a
it's more of a heart-to-heart two guys
just bullshitting
it's the first time i saw him in 11
months and it's it's a [__] pleasure
man because
i do miss him you know i talk a lot of
[__]
but i miss a lot of my old school
friends from l.a yeah i miss rogan
i miss red band i spoke to them this
weekend you know hari was down in austin
so they called me kate is down there
this week so red band will call me again
red band went to my favorite restaurant
in austin
and took a picture and [__] called me
that night and he goes it's not what it
used to be
because the covert they don't have the
same seafood they have a limited [__]
menu
he went to papados crossing the
doubletree in austin
that was my [__] spot for years so
i'm still talking to my tight buds but
this one today
was extra special we even that night
after we finished the podcast he called
me back that night
and we chit-chatted for another [__]
45 minutes just about life
and whatnot i'm talking about felipe
[__] esparza
he came to my wedding i didn't go to his
because i had a gate
gig in chicago you know
he executive produced my special when he
won last comic standing
he called me first from the stage and he
goes nobody [__] knows dawg but
you and i did so many shows together i
gotta tell you i one last comic standing
and i remember pulling over i was on
melrose
and like fairfax and i remember pulling
over
and actually like being so [__] happy
for felipe to win last comic standing
he was part of the crew you know he
would hang with me ralphie
we used to do acting classes on tuesday
our own acting classes i mean you know
hard work is hard work guys and uh this
guy i give him all the respect in the
world enjoy felipe esparza [__]
i'll see you back in i don't know 30
minutes
what up fool what's up fool how are you
my little brother of love
chillin man what's up fool i can't call
it
just checking in with you i got my
lakers shirt on out of respect
for los angeles you know how we do it
play
you know me how you been i've been great
man how you been
good trying to put the pieces together
missing you you know thinking about you
every time i see narcos
yeah i'm about to see this thing alone
[__] i go that's my boy felipe
straight out of cinderella and [__]
[Music]
you've been down there lately no i
haven't been down there man but
i i i met one of the actors
from narcos at a a movie premiere
for some movie i'm in you know the cop
that's playing
um one of the federal cops that's
actually a good cop
and he's there when they're
interrogating the guy who killed
camarena
i kind of and the doctor has been
uh he's been tortured he's telling that
mexican cop
because you think these cops care about
you guys after this done
i'm going after your families
i'm one of the best christians i met him
yeah that's a crazy ass [__] show i
love
uh i loved the first two seasons i loved
cali but
[__] mexico was straight-up gangster
the whole [__] diego luna
yeah man i just [__] love he's a
great actor i just watched the scene the
night where he has to meet pablo
when pablo kidnaps him and [__] and he
tells him the hippopotamus don't like
mexicans
and all that [__] it's [__] it's like
de niro and pacino sitting down in heat
that's
two [__] strong actors what else has
been happening in your life
not much man going back on tour i have a
new tour coming up it's
unmasked tour i'm going a lot of cities
man
starting next week you're a bad
[__] let me ask you something
you were the first person to do a
spanish special correct
english and english simultaneously on
netflix first
you were the first one because i read
something last year and i know you were
pissed off
somebody said this was the first spanish
[__] netflix special you're like [__]
that
it was felipe jack don't [__] forget
baby
and i know yes it was me man and um
hopefully there'll be more so we could
do a mexican-american
comedy tour in a latin country that
would [__] work in south america
and all those places it would work it's
amazing
yes i would like to go somewhere on tour
where i don't have to do a whole hour
you know
i'd like to just do my little 25 minutes
and get the hell out of there
maybe i could go on tour in spanish with
tom suguro or jesus trejo
and hook up with carlos ballarta in
mexico and
make him get the party started
and just go up and down mexico just make
sure you don't [__] get mugged or
shaken down and
you know it was it was really
interesting to me when i saw
the rolling stones documentary oleola
have you ever seen it i haven't seen it
they did all the south america
south america and mexico are are big
markets for big markets punk rock
heavy metal and comedy yeah if i had my
[__] passport i'd go to south america
and drop some knowledge on those
venezuelans and [__]
man you go to you want to go to a badass
punk
rock concert you go you go to chile man
chili has the biggest punk rock um
convention in the whole wide world man
like all the bands that you
that you grew up with that you might
think oh man i wish i could
go see them like they're playing in peru
man like
the ramones are huge over there man
huge it's funny because when i watched
that documentary
there was i think it's chile where the
stones are [__]
huge like they have stones clubs
you know they they it was just amazing
so i
i always thought about you when you did
that tour
to maybe do [__] south america
colombia
you know venezuela costa rica the whole
[__] thing that's that's just an
option
some people go to australia you know you
could go to [__] south america
i love to go to australia man i've been
dying to go to um
auckland new zealand man i heard it's
nice
i want to go over there man i want to
get treated i want to get treated with
by the mari's bro
the real the the other mexicans bro in
europe
that's [__] i think though the maori
are badass bro like new zealand natives
a lot of those guys who are great actors
they come to america and play mexican
parts
like that have you seen that movie uh
with denzel washington
which one when he goes you were you
already got your sh you
got your [__] pushed man what is that
when he's um
well now training day okay
training day when he's in when uh that
other actor um
ethan hawk he's he's about to get killed
by the mexican gangsters
the main one the main leader of the of
the of the cholos
he's not even a mexican he's right i
know you're talking about
i know you're talking about he plays a
lot of sp he even played
pablo escobar and blow and blow a badass
movie
yeah yeah he played pablo escobar on
[__] blow
how does it feel acting i know you're
digging it
i love how the [__] shows and movies
and whatnot what's going on with you
i'm in a movie right now with uh omar
chaparro he's a real big a mexican actor
from mexico and he's a comedian actor
over there
with millions of fans and he did a movie
in english called
seventh and union it's like it's like a
rocky story but with a mexican in it
just kind of day laborer in the morning
and he plays
he fights he bar he fights in bars at
night
like clean ease would growing every
which way but loose
like charles brown hard times
yes so he's fighting man and
i mean i mean like his best friend at
work so every time he's at work
i'm in the scene i'm in a lot of scenes
man like
when the movie was shown at the chinese
theater
when it started i was very surprised to
see um
when when all the credits started and
then at the end i said
and felipe esparza you dig that huh
do you remember mock acting classes
behind my building
yes man it was me you cisco rodrigo
and rick ramos how [__] crazy is that
we used to go
we would get high and then just go get
mad because his son was there nobody
told you to bring him [__]
that's right cisco would bring his
[__] son there that's right
and then we're our we're all doing the
scene
of um which is the real hearts you'll
give us the hardest scenes
to do bro for young actors like
the scene you gave us was the one where
where it was bronx with with um it was
um
[__] can you remember it was um the
movie was al pacino where al pacino is a
gangster he's
alito's way and um
what's the name of johnny depp he's a
cop
wow i thought i did not was part of the
banana family
daddy brasco yes donnie brass okay the
scene where al pacino's son
his son od again that's right
and um you were playing al pacino
and we were playing johnny depp and
we'll take alternating turns
and you know we're trying to get us to
take an emotion
that his son is old dean for the third
time already
not the first time first time we were
sad but then the third time
he's still [__] sad you were telling
us but he's angry too
we were trying to relate that emotion
but we were [__] high
we used to get high on tuesdays because
the guy
at that [__] weed store on tuesday
would make the edibles fresh he was a
chef
yeah he didn't make chocolate and he
would hook us up just give us stuff and
i still remember the day we had to carry
rodrigo
into the car his legs were [__] his
legs were dragging
like tarantino when they walked him out
of el compadre that night
they two mexicans walked out quentin
tarantino
and his legs were [__] dragging on
the floor and they basically just put
him in his car and closed the [__]
door i don't know what happened to
quentin after that
maybe he ended up at harvey weinstein's
house who the [__] knows he was on rogan
last week
talking a bunch of [__] nonsense [__]
him i can't stand quentin tarantino i
really can't
he i hate his [__]
trying to make bruce lee look bad i
[__] hate his movies
his movies are always like there's a guy
like wink wink it's
just hollywoody and [__] if you're gonna
[__] tell me that that tarantino dude
didn't know about harvey weinstein and
what he was doing
you're [__] full of [__] they all
[__] knew so i i don't even
i've never even watched that [__]
movie about hollywood
i never watched the django unchained i
didn't i stopped watching this [__]
15 [__] years ago he got on my last
nerve so
people were all impressed because he was
on rogan last week [__] telling lies
[__] him
he could suck david chase's [__] dick
but david chase forgot
quentin tarantino don't know kill bill
he stole that from [__] uh
what's the other guy that came after
bruce lee that was a savage
sonny cheaters sonny nobody remembers
sonny [__] chiba movies and [__]
he had that one movie that was wild like
[__]
badass bro he would like die hard before
die hard [__] yeah sonny chiba put out
one
like four or five movies but there was
one of them that was just
[__] ultra violent i gotta look it up
i used to do the martial arts uh
movie segment for national lampoon years
ago
so i had to look all those [__]
movies up to shiro mi fooney
and [__] sonny chiba and that's where
he got killed bill from he stole [__]
all the bits from them he even put sonny
sheba
at the in his movie as a sword maker
right he was a sword maker in that movie
that's right that's right yeah but but
study sheba first
when when christopher torrentino first
introduced him
like we didn't already know was in that
movie true romance a movie that he wrote
but didn't direct it was directed by
that bad [__] bro
what's his name man their brother one of
them died
really scott okay so
true romance is a quentin tarantino
written movie
yes but uh
he directed it but he cut up all of um
crystal torrentino's lines because the
movie was full of um
full of quarantino lines like remember
that scene where um
when um christian slater walks in to to
grab his
rosetta arquette suitcase because uh
what's his name is there um gary oldman
is there playing like a
like a black guy that was the rockstar
yeah
yeah and he goes in there man you go how
come you don't sit down
i don't sit down because that i already
seen this movie it's
it's a mac with pam greer richard pryor
you know i already saw this movie but
the original line was
i don't want to watch this movie because
i it's pam greer
and richard pryor and he gets into a
long unuseful dialogue about
cinematography on the cinematography was
this
and that movie was shot with this type
of lights you know all that [__]
lines that kevin smith likes to do also
like in clerks
nonsense
he likes to give you a movie history i
don't need a movie history
give me good dialogue [__] movie
history i don't want to know where the
movie was made
and the movie is being made just give me
the [__] movie man
who's going to shoot it who i don't want
to know that when the movie was made
there was good lighting the sound man
was the oscar-winning sound man
[__] all that man get to the dialogue eh
this is your make my day [__]
clean eastwood style
yeah and the least is the better the
least you say is the [__] better i
hate
[__] i got offered this mob movie
that it would have taken me two years to
learn my lines
it would have taken me two [__] years
the guy hit me up and he's like
he hit me up in july uh it's going it's
going
then he hit me up december 8th he's like
this is the week i need you in new york
i go
for [__] scale new york december 8th
in the winter
i'm moving with val kilmer and that's it
i'm i'm not [__] wasting my time i
i'm never going to learn this dialogue
i don't know what you're talking about
you do i saw a trailer for that movie
that movie has everybody belt kilmer it
has big [__]
big [__] michael that guy
from doogie hauser that little italian
guy
he has everybody in it oh benny benny i
just did uh
a thing with him in new york we played
detectives
yeah i saw the movie you said no to him
that movie has everybody in it man
but i still don't know what it's about
yeah
it was listen when you send me a mob
script and i see
geno tony or the name
anthony i turn it down i turn it i turn
it down just by reading the first
five pages because if you're still
making those type of movies they're just
not [__] gonna go
the sopranos covered everything
me too man like i don't turn down movies
because i'll get offered too many
but i kind of like i have one i i'm
listening with one eye already shut
without even looking at it like this
like
like i know that i know that that's not
gonna work you know right now
i know that that that type of movie is
not gonna work right now when
there's a page called who's gone wild
and they created that page on themselves
and now they're doing concerts
with that type of comedy with millions
of followers
and you're trying to come up here with
this latino movie
with a message for everybody let me tell
you man
we're going to start make stop making
mexican american films or any
spanish film with a message at the end
we don't want a message
when i watch die hard there's no [__]
message you know what the message was
i should have bought more popcorn you
know what i mean
all these movies
go ahead i should have had more guns
that's what he should have had in
[__] dead
yeah we want a movie with daddy
schweighl we're in a cave shooting
people that's
it i can't remember the movie we did
where the guy put a fake mustache on me
oh my god cause you shaved i shaved i
didn't know i had a [__] i couldn't
grow a mustache if you [__] paid me
okay
and he [__] yeah he made me the
sheriff for the [__] shitty mustache
that director was the biggest
waste of time felipe that was like
that was definitely a [__] money too
the money wasn't bad right no he wasted
money on stuff that
that we didn't need to like honestly joy
me
you nikko turo and two other people
that we had to hire a stunt coordinator
to do the stuff that we were doing out
there
nah it was a [__] nightmare the only
thing that guy was taking an hour
teaching the karate moves
yes that's right that was terrible
terrible i [__] hated all that [__]
the only thing that
came out of that movie was david provo
we got him high
oh my god jackie april we [__] turned
them on to edibles and [__] he came the
next day where do i get a marijuana card
i just talked to him about a year ago i
was like thank god for turning me on to
that [__] my life changed
that was funny because um the the
director made him
made him a french guy in the movie when
this guy played italians
everywhere and then and then um he got
french guy
how do i do how the [__] will do a
french accent smoke some of this
we get i was just saying that we got
high all day because they couldn't find
paul rodriguez
that's right paul was m.i.a and [__]
they had to go to his house and jump the
fence
and get him and [__] how's he doing is
he better now
he's doing good man i haven't spoken to
him but
we have the same agent and i see that
he's getting back on the road
okay yeah because he was in the hospital
for a while wasn't he
yeah he was in the hospital something
was wrong with him he drank bad water he
was
funny he was dehydrated and um
he had just came from a rally where he
was fighting
for water for the farmers
and he was dehydrated yes [__]
tremendous instead of fighting for the
[__] farmers he should have drank a
glass of wine or water
i opened up i opened up for him him and
i mentioned my him and i did a show
and um you know when i started stand-up
comedy
the latino comedians that were
headlining were only george lopez and
carlo mancia and paul rodriguez park and
um paula francisco
everybody else was featuring and barely
headlining but those guys were
headlining
and um i remember opening up for paul
rodriguez and reno california
and he called me up you know like
busting my balls
and he because he found out that i was
arguing with somebody i guess
somewhere else somebody told them you
know comedians trying to rat you out
so you won't open up for somebody maybe
he'll take me
you know so he calls me up and go what
is this you complaining about
your hotel is too small your airplane
seat was horrible
it was bad weather and going wasn't they
complaining about nothing man what's
wrong with your ass
then he goes you start complaining once
you see my room
and he hung up i opened
for him with mark babbitt remember mark
babbitt
houston remember you were the first time
i you met mark babbitt
i remember because par i think um you
might have met willie barcena for the
first time
and um he he he kept talking to willie
kim talking about how you and bart
babbitt hit it off right away i liked
mark babbitt
mark mark babbitt he was the first guy i
ever sent
a blank tape to like he told me to send
them a tape to open up for bobby slayton
and i kept telling them i ain't sending
you a tape i kept sending them rosters
from the comedy store
i go why would i send you a tape i
follow paul mooney every night if you
can't live with that
go [__] yourself he's like listen i
really want to book you but i need a
tape
so i sent him a blank tape and he called
me right away he goes your tape was
tremendous
you're working with bobby slayton that
was the first i swear to god i sent him
a [__] blank tape
till this day he probably didn't watch
it because you ever go to a manager's
office to get paid
what do they got behind though a bunch
of blank tapes of dust on them they
don't look at them
a bunch of dust a dust off dust on them
and then
whatever year you're there a lot of
young comics that are probably famous
now are there
collecting dust look at all the [__]
people we
we watched blow up felipe i watched you
blow up
you know i mean we go back to 97 at the
[__] brave bull with rudy
and i watched you blow up i remember you
still calling me from the set of last
comic
telling me i [__] did it you know i
saw you [__] blow
up put them to shame we want we saw
tiffany haddish blow up [__]
definitely was nothing she was walking
around the lap
going on the road with red bands tiffany
was on my year bro
tiffany had watch top 40 here are the
top 40 people
up that are big now that were on last
comic standing
2010 season seven
they made it mainly made probably the
top 20 but
this was top 40. chiffonade was on my
top 40.
cristela alonso was my top 40. little
rail bro little rail
was top 40. um oh that one
writer from new york man he's very funny
he writes for amy schumer he got into a
little trouble
he he's so funny man he was top 40. hell
yeah man
i gave him edibles in my [__] hotel
room who will the
the year you made it i would have never
thought i made it man
but who were the finalists that year
that you beat out our top
ten top ten five the five was
the top five was um me
tommy john again mike kaplan
roy woods jr and mike distefano
rest in peace wow mikey that's stefano
bro like that the whanau like he was
killing it on on the tour bro like like
i'm glad he was third
and not second place because he was like
getting standing ovations
when he was struggling and um tommy john
again
couldn't follow him so by the time um he
will go out
after after mike tommy will try to do
like
18 20 minutes just to get some heat
going you know
because he was leaving a lot of heat
behind bro it was like following you bro
when you're hot
you know when you're hot come on bro
when you do a
a tie 20 nobody in the world can follow
you
they're hot 20th and you even told me my
if you have a
hot 15 hot 20 you're unstoppable the
rest of the 25 will come naturally
oh yeah the first 18 i'll [__] knock
it out of the park i don't [__] around
those comedy store sets
they make you [__] savage so if
you're gonna give me 18 minutes
and you're gonna [__] cause i'm gonna
condense
48 into 18. i'm not going to shut the
[__] up i'm just going to keep coming at
you till you can't
take it no more you know that's why i
hated i hated headlining
because you got to do 45 [__] long
minutes
you got to space out your jokes so i
would have to write like an
hour 20 to really kill on a headlining
set because i want a machine gun to
death
i want to machine gun them take a
breather step
back let him get some mail and take a
sip of the drink and then go in there
again
step back at the 32 minute mark 33
minute mark
give him another breather and then just
bring it on [__] home like pete rose
in the all-star game
when he left that dude down that's it i
just want to bring it the [__] home
that's why i haven't been going on the
road because i don't have that type of
material anymore i got to start all over
from [__] scratch
so i just been taking my time podcasting
[__] around spending time with my
daughter you know it's nice so
it's [__] hot here it's starting to
get humid so i don't want to do comedy
outside i don't want to do dick
i i know what you me what you mean up
that's very important
so anybody listening here who's the
young comic and you're worried about it
i should get an
hour no bro forget the hour go for the
because everybody that has a type 45
it's the type 45
when the crowd is hot you know when it's
packed
that's a type 45 perfect but there's
going to be times when the infinite the
chronic ain't going to be hot
and you're going to go through that 45
minutes and 30.
are you gonna go through that one hour
in 30 minutes
i've been there man you've been here
remember that one time you came back
with that sad story
what happened i tried to do your
material they didn't want it
i get a phrase i get us a willie
barcelona they say [__] no
i give freddy soto they said [__] you
what is that
it's crazy when you're up there like you
know
what the thing was with a guy like guys
with me and you
and it pisses me off a lot because
people don't get it
i hate when people go to me because i
was one of those guys
and it was a big mistake i made it's
like hey man i got 45.
listen there's a big difference between
having 45
and there's a big difference between
being a headliner
you know like i took a year i took a
year where
every thursday i would go to irvine and
watch the headline i wouldn't say hello
to him
i wouldn't even let him know i was there
and the best three headliners i saw that
ye at irvine were patrice o'neill
greg geraldo and ralphie may
ralphie may knew how to [__] headline
he was a headliner
for a long time i remember the first
time i started headlining
i was in the headline i remember eating
a bag of dicks the columbus funny bone
for like the first three weeks of that
tour i just ate a bag of dicks and then
you put it together you learn
how to headline you learn how to
you know [__] be presentable and then
remember a lot of guys don't like when
they drop checks
i love when they drop checks that's what
my dick gets hard
because i got to bring them out of the
[__] abyss because they just looked
at the tab and go who the
96 who drank the long island
so there's always that little lull in
the audience when they get their tabs
there's a lot of comics
that don't like the tabs drop while
they're on stage
they want it they hate it they hate it i
like it
enough it's another challenge it's just
another challenge and now
you get to run them for [__] 10
minutes like that's that break i like
that that 34 minute mark when they drop
those checks
oh that's when i start sipping water
without them seeing i slip a [__]
home stretch that's the home stretch
nobody even knows i got my little edible
right there
i know i'll be high by the time i get to
the hotel room
and i'll just pop it without them
knowing it like making believe i'm
drinking a lot of times i just put it in
the [__] water
and drink the water just it just melts
in the [__] water
and those last 12 13 minutes i want them
to be
[__] heat like i told these guys i
said you know what you want me on the
road
i'll charge you 40 bucks and i go out
there and improvise and it's a 50 50
show
you know you might leave happy or you
might leave depressed
i rather go out when i got a [__]
good hour of what's going on with my
life and that's what i'm
doing now i'm trying to live my life so
i come up with a new [__] hour
so when the soprano movie comes out at
least i can travel new jersey
pennsylvania dc you know around here i'm
not getting on no [__] planes felipe
for a while
no i'm i'm worried you don't want to be
on a plane i was on a plane last week
on american and everything was going
great
i would fly from atlanta to philadelphia
and um we stood in a turmeric for two
hours and 45 minutes
it was getting hot and yeah
the captain kept coming up with this you
know they come up with excuses
he goes oh we're checking in for the
bad weather in philadelphia man it's
very foggy then now an hour later
uh we're about to drive good on a runway
and southwest
took our driveway our our turn really
southwest cut you off on the runway
how does this southwest cut off american
i know west is a step above [__] bro
[__] back the [__] southwest little
dog i flew a couple weeks ago i had to
go to the cabin i was so angry bro
i had to go to california to close the
weed deal and let me tell you something
i couldn't even find a direct flight
back
everything is connecting they got to be
bullshitting you because they're saying
that there's a million travelers a day
but they don't have look at you had to
go all the way to atlanta to get to
philly
yeah so there was no direct flights to
philly they were too expensive
there were none none none so how the
[__]
a million people flying you can't even
get to it like when i
came back i tried jetblue from burbank
because they got a burbank to [__]
kennedy they shut that line down
there's no more burbank the [__]
kennedy out of burbank
so they were both there was only two
direct flights on jetblue that day
everything else was connecting you gotta
go to boston
sit for two hours until you ask grows
roots and your hemorrhoids [__]
back up and then you gotta i'm not doing
it i don't wanna lose my luggage
you know if [__] there's no employees
last time i flew somewhere when i came
back on the way there i got my luggage
quick
but when i got to newark i waited a
[__] hour for my luggage
so i'm done with that [__] i'll relax
this summer wait for it to get back to
normal people are throwing fits on
airlines
they are man every day there's an unruly
guy that don't want to [__] put a
mask on
you know [__] that i'm not going to play
karate chop on the [__] plane with
nobody you know
i know man we're when we were traveling
rachel wilson
she was sitting next to this chubby man
you know
real midwestern man and his mask
he killed he was snoring and his mask
kept coming now when he was snoring
and his mask was full of like his saliva
already
it was just coming off him garlic and
rachel wolfson was trying to move seeds
they told her no
no they won't let you move they won't
let you do [__] so
no you know what man it's a little wild
out there right now
so i'm pretty cool i'm worried about you
guys going out but you're [__]
you've been doing this for 30 [__]
years you're a savage plus you're a
tough guy
you'll smack somebody you got a good
crew with you
you got my man rodrigo you got rizzo you
got
rachel you know chuck bartell
now we have gabby lamb lambie okay
we got butch escobar too how's butch
doing
he's good man he's living in berkeley
he's raising his son
you know with him by himself with his
his um baby mama
they take to take turns you know it's
tough
and i know you got your daughter now and
you got your grandchild
living with you so my heart yeah my
daughter um
my daughter's going through chemo so i
take her son in the morning i take him
to school
and i bring him back it's like being a
dad again
you enjoying it i love it man um
my son is well my grandson is two he
doesn't know how to say grandpa he just
yelled out she's shot
and you know joey man is like
like i took my kids to school but i
guess i was never around you know
with their moms to hear stuff like about
my son at school
you know but man when you have a
grandson or a two-year-old
my son is in months either in montessori
school
right daycare from seven
to six but i pick him up at three
man every day they tell you something
bad that he did like
you know your son bid like five kids
today or
your son put somebody's hair finally
like
a month later the teacher came up to me
really sad
i thought he was going to kick him i
thought they were going to kick him out
of the school already because then we
got like three warnings
he bites someone else this two-year-old
is out of the school
so she tells me our little girl bit his
uh a little girl bit your son
and i was like oh thank god my son is
getting better
they're biting him now
it's [__] crazy and your little
grandson lives with you
yeah he lives with um my daughter they
live like i'm two blocks away
so they really live close but where
right now we're gonna
tear down our garage and make them a
little tiny home next door
so they could come in and out of our
house good for you i'm gonna have to go
pick them up yeah
you know felipe and that was my thing
too my daughter just turned eight
we just moved back here she's
discovering a whole different [__]
world
she's a different kid you know today she
started camp she left here with a cowboy
hat this morning
i didn't even know what the [__] to say
she just gave me a kiss i told her
what's up with the hat she goes it's
cowboy day
whatever you know what am i going to do
and i want to watch her grow up
i want to be here for a few years
locally you know she uh sat me down
like two years ago not even uh right
before the pandemic she's like i don't
like when you leave
you know i left like a valentine's day
present she's like it would have been
better if you would have gave it to me
personally
so you know what man i've been doing
this i mean felipe i met you in 97
and we were out seven nights a week
felipe last i [__] seven nights a
week
we were out eight nights a week you know
uh monday the laugh factory tuesday
you and willie had the room wednesday
out coyote
with the twins yeah with the [__] you
always give me a burrito that was my
dinner
and sunday potluck for the sunday
potluck
and you know i mean we've have been
[__] fighting for our lives
for years how long have you been doing
comedy in the total right now
since uh 95 27 years
24 i started four years before you so
when i met you you were in comedy two
years
that's what you're telling me when i met
you in 97
yeah whenever you're 97 i had started i
had a
i already had a tv created because jeff
brought this
had latino night latino showtime
laugh festival with um a bunch of comics
so i did that
but at 90 my son was born in 93
four and i had quit comedy so yeah like
late 93 bro like a lot of years
27 years but headlining
and making money and having fun i've
always had fun though
but i'm actually taking a serious 2010.
me too like a headliner
2013. yeah i think i started because i
2009 i got married and i was like you
know what i'm gonna give comedy a break
maybe i'll get a job selling cars and
then the podcast world started
and we started podcasting and next thing
you know you know tickets are selling so
we had to adjust to what was coming in
you know i didn't think that
i was ever going to go back on the road
and
like i talked to my agent yesterday we
were like we did a hell of a [__] run
you know we got all the way to the
[__]
chicago theater and sold out two shows
we sold out two shows in new york at the
theater so it was a great run
i'll tell you what if it's up to me i
don't want to do theaters no more
i want to go back to the brick wall you
know the theaters were a little too
rough for me
i don't like taking that saturday
[__] plane my back is killing me i'm
too [__] old
i like relaxing on saturdays so when i
go back i'm just going to go out fridays
and saturdays
four shows get me the [__] out of here
abandon [__] or do wednesday nights like
i'm i'm thinking of doing a residency
in atlantic city or at the count basie
theater and it would just be like once a
week or something
you know i'll start doing guest sets
like in august maybe because i'm feeling
better so
i might as well [__] go for it and
[__] are you still on super show
whatever on nbc or they cancel that
they canceled superstore after five
seasons but i'm in um the last season
five episodes they gave me a lot of
episodes bro and um
we'll see what happens after that but
speaking of shows
um you're right about theaters because
i've been going to portland to do the
revolution hall
you know but last year i went to helium
to do like three show four shows for 100
people like during the pandemic
but i'm going back and i'm going to be
there thursday through sunday at helium
in like in november
so yeah man i really wanted to be in
portland more than one day you know
it's fun that's a great comedy club i
got to give you that the lady who runs
helium portland
is [__] tremendous they got tater
tots they got a spicy ranch
i don't even like ranch [__] dressing
they got a red spicy ranch dressing
that they put on the tater tots don't
make your [__] [__] open up and
down it's [__] tremendous you know
what i'm saying so
uh i like portland but there's a lot of
[__] going on in portland so you got to
be crazy
you got to be careful you got to be
careful because i think they're only
doing like six o'clock shows
you gotta be in by ten o'clock or
something like that i think i was there
i was there bro when they were when they
had curfews they had a they had to
stop studying alcohol at nine pm yeah
and we were at a hundred people per show
it was edwin san juan rodrigo and i and
martin rizzo
bro right outside the helium comedy club
somebody crashed an suv and
broke in there and everybody ran off
with bicycles
every night we were there there was a
fire somewhere so we didn't really go
out bro we just stood in
there was a there was a little weed shop
across those people in my hotel room
and there's a wheat shop right around
the corner from the club
yes that's really good they tell you to
go over there when you get
to the club so i used to go over there
by like [__]
lurch weed and then hang out dog i
[__] set the fire alarm off at the
portland helium
the [__] felicia was up on stage and
i'll send you her bra
they were like [__] 20 000 comics
have come here and smoked
dope you're the one that sets off the
[__] fire alarm what the hell is
wrong with you
i loved it i got the reputation [__]
them
hell yeah man gotta do something you're
still going acting classes
every i have acting class today four to
five with deborah lemon
i go there every week bro every week i
go to an acting class i know you
you stuck with it for a while and i'm
really proud of you felipe i gotta tell
you man
i was watching narcos the other night i
was thinking about it was too late to
call you
the next day you called me
and then i was [__] you know it was
fourth of july weekend i had my
daughter pools parties
you know and then i called you back and
i felt back as you were at sojos
i would have [__] brought you some
weed an edible something i'll give you a
hug
you know so next time you're in this
before give me a call during the week
because if you call me friday afternoon
i'm with [__] i'm surrounded by eight
sets of parents
and uh you know you're still smoking
still smoking still eating edibles
shrooming every once in a while it's
chocolates everyone
people give them to me those are good
those chocolate covered [__] i just
ate some in new york when i shot
i shot a tv show and one of the ushers i
gave him weed and he goes hey i got
something for you
he gave me a little piece of chocolate
covered mushrooms i had to drive i
didn't feel it
but [__] it i don't feel a lot of
[__] things you know what i'm saying
i'm getting too old
i ate half of one and i watched um
clothing counters for the first time
who wouldn't content that movie a
clothing culture or the third kind
everybody came for yeah that's a good
movie i haven't seen it in [__] 30
years so
where's your tour start mature stars
um in a couple actually starts
this week at the tempe improv and then
we're going to hit up by celia
modesto monterey salinas
all kinds of places not some some
shows we don't we don't have dates for
like chicago no dates
but they're they're coming man check
them out at philippinesworld.com tour
but this week i'll be at the tempe
improv
and then the following week about the
addison improv
so look out for those shows listen man
uh i gotta be honest with you there's a
lot of people i don't miss
in l.a you know what i'm saying like
there's a lot of people i don't miss
i don't miss none of the [__] stars i
don't miss none of the douchebags but
you're one guy i miss you know i talked
to rodrigo a couple of [__] days ago
i checked them with him uh
i miss steve simone i miss jerry rocha
you know
i miss the [__] our little crew
you know rodrigo's a good man but most
importantly i miss you man i'm happy
you're doing well
and i'm happy you're still an acting
class and i'm happy you're still [__]
telling these [__] to suck your
dick your way you don't give a [__]
we've been the same way for 40 30
[__] years
what was the name of the club on tuesday
nights we used to go to
where i would no that was
fly's room yeah the one you and willie
had that they cleaned out and they
turned into a car lot
all the way out there you guys had a
tuesday and a wednesday for a while
well
on wednesday and that place was called
um daily planning on tuesday and
daily planning on tuesday
that's right casa latina was tuesday's
that was fly's room where they gave you
tacos
yeah uh ernie jean [__] mambo room up
at the university
monday nights was the mambo room and
the laughter commerce casino thursday
was commerce casino
listen to the [__] lineup we had the
gentleman and then you started the
comedy store late night
we had commerce and then gilbert
had a room in not long beach but
wherever he's from where's gilbert
esquivel from does he's from wilmington
wilmington he had the bfw and the best
of street that
the best [__] tacos in the world for
50 cents he would pay me 50 bucks and i
would eat 50
worth of tacos at 50 [__] center taco
i remember i brought my drug dealer down
there with me one time
dante dante i was up on stage and while
i came off
he he came back with two plates of
[__] tacos he goes man these tacos
are fantastic i'm like [__] it
i went and got 50 of them and we [__]
tore them down
i used to call gilbert just to book me
in that room so i could get the tacos
yeah that was so that was the the tacos
that's on pch and third street by the
way if anybody wants to know
wow i don't know if they're still there
by now that was 15 [__] years ago but
i loved
you know man the the spanish the mexican
community opened up their [__]
arms to me and it was because of you and
i'll never forget you because of that
you turned me on to king taco
the chorizo mashed potato [__] no no
no
chicharrones and mashed potato
[__] burrito with the security guard
there it got to the point
burrito yeah that was the green pork
burrito you should get
all the green sauce on top and the
cheese and they had like
big chunks of beef inside people wonder
why i got so big in the longest yard it
was because of [__] felipe in his
mexican rooms
every [__] night on the way back i
would stop at king taco man and get a
taco there
and a taco to eat on the way to the
[__] comedy store that's when you
know you're a fat
[__] but everybody ever wonder why
king chocolate has so many security
guards like they're all having business
you thought it was a bank what about the
night we almost got janked
in stockton remember that the guy told
us to get in the car with him we have
money
first of all it was a bad night that was
the the day the raiders lost to the
[__] patriots
on the no talk rule so everybody at that
stadium everybody on our show
was a [__] raider fan and these black
dudes were
angry angry and they all they all wanted
to take us to the strip part
they did they were going to fight that
man they all wanted to give us drugs
they all wanted to take us
everywhere they did give us drugs they
didn't give me coke they gave me a
[__] gram of meth
and you me and rodrigo sat in the room
with the door open and i must have
smoked
80 cigarettes i i thought it was coke it
was [__] speed
my jaw was going i was sweating my dick
went into my nutsack and shrunk and it
went in all that was hanging was a
little flap from the uncircumcision
it looked like a [__] wind flap it
was terrible what a horrible night i was
so embarrassed in front of you guys
you were [__] uh we were watching the
movie familia
yeah morales yes when the little kid
walks out and he goes pinching
his or whatever pinch
and he's [__] naked that was yeah
how many estimate estimate how many
shows we did together just
for [__] fun and laughs 500 a
thousand
500 a thousand man we used to go up
north
there was a mexican room up north not
only that but you've done
shows that i've done that people
probably never ever heard of like
that room man and and uh [__] man
since and um and labuk
iowa why these both whitey's billions
bro
that place is crazy dog
that was the that's labute iowa yes the
capital
of [__] met okay it's the capital of
[__] met
the first show we did was great because
the parents were there
but when the second show started there
was there was 300 people in the place
but only four people sat down
and there was a line to go to the
bathroom and everybody was coked up i
wasn't doing coke then
everybody was cold and i asked the
[__] owner i go listen there's only
two flights out of here in the [__]
morning
because you got to connect from iowa to
chicago and then chicago to iowa there's
only two flights one at like
eight in the morning and one at like
eight o'clock at night
i go if you get [__] up tonight i'm
gonna miss my [__] flight in the
morning i'm gonna [__] kill you
and that [__] missed picking me
up i hunted him down
he came and he did a hundred all the way
to the [__] airport to get me there
on time
and i remember he gave me some extra
money from my [__] uh
you know pain yeah my [__] suffering
that was a hell of a room he contacted
me years later i'm like you're crazy
i never saw and you know for the people
at home
27 years of doing coke i never saw
anything like that in my life
i never saw a place where there was 300
people and 290 of them were coked up and
i'm not talking coke
i'm talking about talking jaws going
cigarettes falling
teeth he does pay you
he does pay you at the airport as soon
as you get to the airport he gave me
money and he goes i'll bring you an
eight ball later i go i don't even do
the [__] coke
what about the club that we used to go
to in uh with the magician
and he'd give you an eight ball of coke
down in midland texas
oh [__] that was his name jenkins
jenkins
holy [__] i remember he gave us
all an eight ball me somebody else and
he was the host
now i'm a fiend guys you know when i did
coke i was a fiend
do you know that this guy came up to me
before the second show was over and he
goes do you have any coke left
i go yeah i go what'd you do you're a
boy he goes i did it already
i go how the [__] did you do an eight
ball in two shows and go out on stage
i never could do coke and go on stage i
did it one time when i first started
like
uh nine months in and i'm like it don't
work for
me i would it would burn a hole in my
pocket felipe you know me i would have
that coke in my pocket it would burn a
hole in there
but i always waited till the end of the
[__] show before i [__] did it so
what are
that was that guy and then now there was
another guy that booked that show
and um odessa where everybody went to
prison
yes midland texas to talk i did so many
shows where the guy would try to
i remember one night marilyn called me
she's like the guy is looking for you
she goes go downstairs and get the coke
and then come up to my room he gave me a
bag of coke
i remember the next day she called me
she goes you're coming to the airport i
go are you
kidding me i didn't even finish the
first bag yet i still got the second bag
to do and i had some mexican chicken in
the room it was [__] crazy
we lived a crazy [__] life felipe
but thank you for calling in today
i miss you with all my heart give my
best to lisa
uh what's up fool comes out when what's
up full podcast every wednesday
8 p.m live on youtube
this is amanda every friday so when you
come back to the east coast you call me
all right brother give me a couple day
notice so i could come and give you a
hug because i miss you
and you were always very good to me you
were a dear friend and i
appreciate you because of that same here
bro
and i'll be anybody listening i'll be
coming to um pittsburgh
improv in august so look out for that
you know i might be up there shooting a
movie so i'll keep you posted
hell yeah for greg garcia tv show i love
you thank you for [__] calling you're
going to beat them
bro i'll bring you some king tacos and
you can eat them cold or microwave them
you got it you got it i love you man
love you too thank you for today brother
thanks for having me
thank you yo man yeah man
all right you bad [__] that was
my man felipe
i hope you enjoyed it i hope it was
[__] long enough for you
uh listen man i have uh i'm getting
better
i feel better thanks to you guys you
know like i said i got the blood test
today i got my little stripe like
frankie five angels
remember godfather two frankie five
angels
was [__] black thing for clemenza
that's me i i'm wearing it
i'm wearing it for i don't know who a
lot of people who passed away this year
from colvin and whatnot but anyway i
want to thank you guys for watching i
wanted you to thank you for
your support uh i still don't know
what's going on in [__] cuba my me
and my cousin spoke and uh
she was out of the [__] country so
she's like i don't know what's going on
i'm trying to call i'm not getting
anything
so i don't know what's going on with my
heart goes out to cuba still i haven't
forgotten about you
and don't forget about [__]
[__] laughing gas
it's still alive and kicking it's
kicking this reef is kicking i was
telling mike
that i'm up to smoking joints now so i
smoked a joint last night of it like i
would roll a joint
and smoke it and then you know it was
just a half a joint but the other night
i had to smoke a half and i'm like wait
a second
i can need some you know like when you
fill a half a tank you're like what am i
doing i need to fill it up to full
that was what happened the other night i
had to come back in roll another doob
and i smoked half of that and then last
night i go [__] it i'm just going for
the full [__] joint but
now that we got the freezer bombs the
freezer bongs and the freezer pipes
you're gonna [__] love it i love you
guys dog with all my heart don't forget
to stop by
ice cream shop dispensary up on ventura
boulevard in studio city
stop by say hello they got abx capsules
they got [__] laughing gas weed
they got everything there you know they
got the best stuff there i've been doing
business with them for years
they're honest and their weed is [__]
tremendous you're gonna love them
besides that
thank you for sharing uh a piece of your
wednesday with me it's just an hour but
it is what the [__] it is i'm
appreciating this i'm really having a
great time doing this
and i'm happy you guys are having a
great time also
thank you very much we'll be back monday
tip
top [__] magoo to rock your
world
and uh you're gonna love it that's all i
got for you have a great weekend
and stay black [__] sucker now for a
word for my [__] sponsors jack
all right [__] i want to thank
you i want to thank felipe esparza
for coming on the show and i want to
thank you guys for always supporting me
in every [__] possible way
whether it's laughing gas the nfts the
patreon you guys are great
or just listening to the joint i love
you guys the joint is brought to you by
upstart
let me ask you like i asked you in the
beginning are you afraid to look at your
credit card statement every month
when you open it do you hear a drum roll
in your head when you're in debt it
could feel
like a never-ending [__] cycle listen
i got into comedy in 97 i am captain
[__] debt
i know all about debt and how to get out
of it but this is tremendous
whether it's paying off your credit
cards or consolidating your debt over
half a million people have used upstart
to get a simple fixed monthly payment
unlike other lenders
upstart looks at more than just your
credit score
they take into account your income and
employment history
this means they can offer you smarter
rates with trusted partners do you
understand
just a five-minute online rate check
that's all and you get approved
the same day so if you go there today
you'll get approved today
and you can receive the funds as quickly
as [__] tomorrow
so by friday you can start paying off
your stuff
if debt is taking over your life it's
time to get a fresh start
with upstart find out how upstart can
lower your monthly payments
today when you go to upstart.com
joey today that's upstart.com
joey don't forget to use the url to let
them know
i sent you you gotta throw in i gotta
throw this in the disclaimer
loan amounts will be determined based on
your credit income and certain other
information provided in your loan
applications
and now go to upstart.com joey and get
out of debt
today the joint is also brought to you
by
holy [__] my favorite freeze pipe
i told you in the beginning for years we
have discussed
how nice it is to put ice cubes in your
bong a little bit of snow in your bong
and smoke do you see the [__] devil
smoking weed doesn't have to hurt your
lungs at all
with freeze pipe you can get an icy cold
hit
every [__] time it comes with a
detachable chamber
you freeze beforehand here's how it
works the smoke passes through the
frozen part
and cools down the smoke as you inhale
it's like putting ice cubes in a bong
but better the coils are made with
glycerin it's non-toxic
freezes faster than water and stays
frozen
longer a lot [__] longer freeze pipe
cools down the smoke by hundreds of
degrees
your throat will thank you whether you
hit a pipe a bubbler a bong or a dab
they got it all i don't have the dab
here i got the pipe
the bubbler and the bong you see the the
pipe and the bubbler i got the bomb
funkle joey
you can't smoke from it it's for me only
you can smoke from it
freeze pipe makes it so do me a favor go
to freezepipe.com right now
freeze pipe f-e-r-f-r-e-e-z-e
freeze pipe dot com and press code joey
this is gonna be
the best bong you ever bought remember
that inexpensive bong i had in the
office
like 800 hours with 800 chamber this
bong hits a lot better
with the freeze pipe trust me so get
your bong
pipe or bubbler today that's
freezepipe.com and pressing code joey
i'm going to save you 10 on a [__]
bomb listen
it's [__] for federal money anyway
what are you gonna do with it you might
as well buy to buy a bong and put a flag
on it you know what i'm saying
that's what a real american does so if
you're gonna go into the murky waters
do it with freeze pipe the bubbler the
pipe or the bong
that's freezepipe.com use codejoey
and get 10 percent off i want to thank
freezepipe
i want to thank upstart i want to thank
manscape
i want to thank cbd lion i want to thank
honda i want to thank everybody
for having our back this week but most
importantly i want to thank you guys
for supporting the joint supporting the
[__] reefer
supporting the patron you guys are
[__] tremendous
i love you [__] don't forget to
get your freeze pipe at freezepipe.com
and don't forget to get your debt
eliminated with upstart
i love you guys see you monday morning
tip
top [__] magoo
there you go and don't forget laughing
gas at the ice cream shop [__]
stay black
have a great week thank you for
listening
[Music]
you